hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we have got the brand new red I
found eight plus this also comes in the
regular sized iPhone 8 version and they
also announced a new red leather folio
case
so not only are so many of you guys huge
fans of the color red but the red color
is not just a color over the past 11
years
Apple has donated over a hundred and
sixty million dollars to the product red
charity red is a charity that provides
testing and counseling and treatments to
tens of millions of people living around
the world with AIDS and HIV so yes it is
a red iPhone but it is for a good cause
and today we are going to unbox that and
I am so excited because when I saw these
photos I was freaking out the news had
already broke on the East Coast and I
was just waking up over here on the west
coast and I was like yes they have a
black front the previous red iPhone that
they released it was a beautiful red
back but the front of it was white so it
seems like Apple has listened to our
feedback and guess what
it's here so sit back relax and enjoy
this wonderful unboxing I know you guys
have never seen me a box and iPhone
before so let's unbox and yes I do
realize that there is a pull tab right
here but what bad
so here we have oh that was surprising
I wasn't ready so let's look we've got
our phone we've got a dongle we've got
our earbuds we've got a power brick and
some wonderful literature instructions
just in case you don't know how to use
it product read pamphlet in partnership
with red apple will contribute a portion
of your iPhone purchase to the Global
Fund to support hiv/aids programs and
help deliver an aids-free generation
learn more or donate at red org we've
also got our lightning cable so I've yet
to look at the back of the phone I'm
gonna show it to you guys first Wow this
is a very very deep red it looks so good
the best part about the iPhone 8 is the
all glass back if you guys recall I did
have the iPhone 8 in the rose gold and
it is probably to date my absolute
favorite color of phone yet that Apple
has ever released with the all glass
back and the aluminum band around it
oh by far this is my favorite design of
iphone to date
it is a really really really really nice
look like I am actually quite a shook I
was so excited about it I said to my
sister and she's like so they're an
iPhone 10 version of this cuz I'm pretty
sure she was about to run to the store
and upgrade her 10 I'm sure a lot of you
guys are probably questioning why did
Apple not release an iPhone 10 version
of this red phone not actually sure but
either way I feel like there is still a
huge market for the iPhone 8 because
this phone is basically an iPhone 10
without facial recognition it really is
a preference essentially the iPhone 8 is
almost the same exact phone as the
iPhone 10 but with a touch ID it also
doesn't do facial recognition there are
a few other features that it doesn't
have over the iPhone 10 but I feel like
at this point it is a preference and I
love that this is still a choice for
people and especially if you are in the
market for a new phone and you want red
this is really beautiful the all-black
front a completely flushed edge to edge
it's honestly really great-looking it's
so hard because I'm looking at this with
my eyes and I'm hoping that I can
portray how incredible this looks to you
guys
hold on smudging it up already I need to
give you guys a good look I think now's
a pretty good time for a slow-mo montage
[Music]
[Applause]
it's it's dusty
guys this is behind the scenes of things
you don't see um no goodness you look
beautiful keep up the good work
[Music]
thank you so much for watching if you
guys enjoyed this video I would love to
hear your feedback of what you guys
think of this phone I definitely
recommend if you have an Apple Store by
you go in and look at it in person
because it is a really beautiful deep
red I mean it's I just I feel like it's
an art piece like this is something that
I want hanging on my wall it might be a
little bit difficult taking phone calls
I'm yeah sorry I can't hear you because
I've decided that I was going to hang up
my phone on the wall as art let me know
if you have any more suggestions for
some videos that you'd like to see here
in the future and don't forget to
subscribe and also make sure you hit
that little bell so that you'll be
notified when I post new videos and with
that I will see you guys in my next
video bye
[Music]